very easy to use um good feel to it I
was impressed enix really high quality
it felt great on my wrist like perfect
size not too big not too small
I'm a Big Apple fan and I just I don't I
like good-looking you know
functional products I don't want to have
to pull up my phone for everything I
have to do I want to expect during
meetings I just want to look at my watch
I'm a tech geek and my co-workers kind
of like expect that I have the newest
and the latest so if I don't have it
they'll look at me and be disappointed
no I don't think I need one I would say
it's a major want not a new do I need it
probably not but I'm gonna get it so
yeah I know it may be obsolete in a year
but then I'll buy another one
I think it'd be a success I need the
applet made many flows that I can
remember anyway I think the low price
watches will be a success I think it
remains to be seen the first orders are
always heavy I don't think it'll be
their most successful product but I
think it's gonna be you know up there
yeah